evening and thanks for joining us
tonight at six o'clock I'm Sasha Loftis
six people are dead after a plane that
came from Las Vegas crashed in
California this morning 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough is live near
Atlantic Aviation on Tropicana and Koval
where the plane took off Madison what
can you tell us tonight
Sasha Atlantic Aviation is considered an
executive terminal of Harry Reid
international airport it's where a lot
of private planes land and take off
according to the Federal Aviation
Association one of those planes is
Cessna 550 crashed into Murrieta
California just after 4 15 this morning
near French Valley Airport in Riverside
County killing six people like you
mentioned now here's what officials from
the national Transportation safety board
had to say earlier in this afternoon's
press conference
when you fly on an instrument approach
you're not going by reference to the
outside of the airplane you're flying
with reference to the inside instruments
on the airplane
um the it appears that the weather was
at the minimums for landing at that
airport so the visibility and ceilings
allowed for a landing but it was right
on the minimums
what's caused this crash is unknown but
the plane went down in a field and burst
into flames the Riverside County
Sheriff's Department stating that they
arrived to the aircraft fully engulfed
as of now the victim's identities have
not been released but the FAA and NTSB
are the ones handling this investigation
as of now keep it here on 8 news now as
we bring you the latest details
reporting near Koval and Tropicana
Madison Kimbrough 8 news now Madison
thank you this is the second plane crash
near French Valley Airport in California
just this week one person died and three
others were hospitalized after a plane
went down there after taking off from
that airport it happened around 3 P.M on
Tuesday this is a look at that scene
this crash also still under
investigation tonight